Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm
Jan and today we're taking a deep
dive into the ending of Season 5 Part 1 to
explain the daddy of all get-togethers,
what the hell Michael is really up to, whether a
demon can actually get a soul, plus predictions
and theories for Part 2 and Season 6!
Just before we begin, many thanks to the
sponsor of this video, Raid Shadow Legends.
We will, of course, be talking spoilers,
so take care if you're not all caught up.
Michael's elaborate plan to ruin his brother's
life appears to be working by the end of Part 1.
He's not only turned Maze against Lucifer,
but he's triggered Amenadiel's fears to
spiral out of control causing time to freeze.
And as the battle between Team Lucifer and Team
Michael comes to a head, in the very final moments
of the Part 1 finale, God arrives to intervene.
"That's enough! Children.
You know I hate it when you fight."
Lucifans have been wondering when
God would finally turn up on the show,
and given the first episode of the second part of
Season 5 is called "Family Dinner", we can expect
to see some interesting family dynamics between
God, Lucifer, Michael, and Amenadiel.
And perhaps Luci's other siblings,
Remy and Azrael, will also make an appearance.
Lucifer's family reunion in the next episode
is bound to relate back to the moment
in Season 5's first episode when Luci
takes Lee to his parents' house where they
were celebrating his sister's baby shower.
Lee says he can't go in to see them because
he's ashamed of what they think of him,
and Lucifer proceeds to berate him:
"Sooner or later, you are going to
disappoint them all over again!
And so you'd rather stay away for all eternity."
As Lee points out, and Lucifer soon realises,
this situation isn't just about Lee;
in fact, it reveals Luci's feelings
about how he relates to his own family.
"This isn't just about me, is it?
Whose Hell is this anyway?"
With Lucifer's dad arriving on the scene,
Lucifer will finally have to confront his own
feelings of shame towards his celestial family.
It'll be interesting to see if Luci continues
to feel guilty for his rebellion
or if he can re-join his family.
Although Lucifer previously said in Season 4 that
he was lying to himself about God manipulating
everything in his life, faced with his Father
now, will any of those old feelings resurface?
"If you mean his plan to continually
manipulate and control me, then agreed."
Also, will Lucifer confront God
over his Mother's claims that God
wanted to destroy Luci after the rebellion?
"I asked him to send you to Hell instead."
And if the Goddess was manipulating
Lucifer about that, it'll be
intriguing to hear God's version of events.
After all, in the "alternate universe" bonus
episode, God said that "a parent just
wants what's best for their child".
But, of course, Michael will
be at the family reunion too
and we know from Amenadiel that Michael has
positioned himself as God's only trusted
advisor to the point that no other
being in Heaven can speak to God.
"He is stronger than you think, Lucy.
Michael's become...
untouchable in the Silver City."
So, what is Michael's grand
plan and what's he really up to?
Well, when Michael explained to Maze why
he came to Earth, he said that he was annoyed at
the praise Lucifer was getting from all the other
angels after he returned to Hell voluntarily.
"Then Raphael starts going off
about how Lucifer's grown,
and then pretty soon all I hear
is, 'Lucifer, Lucifer, Lucifer!'"
Michael's jealous that Luci is getting
kudos for doing what he views as the bare
minimum, just fulfilling his basic role,
something he'd previously been shirking.
Michael also appears to be threatened
by his twin brother's growing maturity and
ability to sacrifice his own happiness in LA
in order to save those he cares for
and do his duty as ruler of Hell.
If God believes that Lucifer has
redeemed himself for his rebellion,
then Michael's favoured position in Heaven
sitting at God's right hand may be in danger.
Because of his inferiority
complex in relation to his twin,
Michael has been constantly plotting to have
Lucifer make decisions that will make him
look "unworthy" in God's eyes all the while
raising his own status in the Silver City.
As Amenadiel pointed out:
"You're terrified that
Lucifer is better than you.
That he'll always be better than you."
According to Michael, he claims he's been
secretly planting ideas in Lucifer's mind
from starting an uprising against God
to his antics in the Garden of Eden.
Michael even says he was responsible
for giving Luci the idea to abandon his
responsibilities in Hell to come to Los Angeles.
Of course, given Michael's tendency to tell lies,
it's possible his claims of controlling
Lucifer's actions are actually false,
and that what he's really doing by telling
his brother that he's been playing him all
this time is preying on Luci's fears;
because if there's one thing we know
about Lucifer, it's that he does not like
to feel that he's being manipulated.
Another part of Michael's plan has
been to exploit Chloe's fears around
her relationship with Lucifer.
After Michael abducts Chloe,
he exposes her concern that Lucifer hasn't
said the exact words "I love you" to her,
something that begins to prey on her mind,
in particular given that earlier Ella was
raving about Pete's "I love meatloaf" line.
"How long did it take Lucifer
to say 'I love you'?"
Michael also tries to worry Chloe about Lucifer's
new-found invincibility when he's with her.
"Him choosing to be vulnerable
around you actually meant something.
Cause you do know that we angels,
we self-actualize, right?"
So, when Chloe's reunited with Lucifer, she
wonders whether subconsciously he's pushing her
away, and if his new invulnerability around her
means he's choosing not be vulnerable with her.
Now, Michael has obviously amplified Chloe's
fear, but I think it's evident that Lucifer
does love her because he finally
attempts to tell her how he feels:
"No, Dete-- Chloe.
I...
I lo--"
Luci may
have been cut off by Amenadiel accidentally
freezing time, but the crucial point to note
here is that Lucifer used Chloe's real name
rather than "Detective", because although
he rarely uses her true name, when he does
it signals his true feelings towards her.
"My first love was never Eve.
It was you, Chloe."
On top of that, Lucifer was desperate to find
Chloe when she disappeared in the final episode,
making it clear that he does love her deeply.
Now, I've got a lot more details to discuss about
Lucifer's new-found invulnerability and the weird
mojo swapping going on between him and Chloe.
That's all in a separate video and I'll add
a card here and a link in the video
description as soon as it's ready.
When it comes to Maze, she's been
through a rough time so far in Season 5
leading her to switch allegiance from Team Lucifer
to Team Michael after he promises he'll get her
the soul she's been longing for.
At the start of the fifth season,
she's already mad at Lucifer for
going down to Hell without her.
And adding to her abandonment issues are Chloe
who splits up their detective partnership;
Eve who left her at the end of Season 4;
and then her mother Lilith who dies a few
days after she sees her again and before
Maze can really tell her how she feels.
Maze believes her lack of a soul is responsible
for her loneliness and blames Lilith for that:
"It was her stupid idea to
have soulless offspring...
making it her stupid fault that I
am doomed to be alone forever."
And when she asks Lucifer if he's
heard of a demon getting a soul,
he enrages her with his dismissive attitude,
even after she points out that nobody heard of
the Devil falling in love before, or of an
angel and a human having a baby together.
"There's a first for everything, right?"
"Well, that's different.
We're angels.
You're just a demon."
The topic of Maze and demons not
having a soul has come up previously,
in particular in the Maze-focussed
episode "Mr and Mrs Mazikeen Smith":
"When I die, that's it.
Maze out."
This season, presenting himself as a
friend to Maze, Michael offers her a
soul which is what she thinks she wants;
although, given his tendency for lying
and manipulating, that's likely to
turn out to be a ruse of sorts.
Instead, what I think could be important to
resolving Maze's existential dilemma is Lucifer's
ring, which her mother Lilith gave him and
which Maze was staring at in the final episode.
We learned in the noir episode that Lilith gave
up her immortality when she blew what looked like
perhaps her own soul or essence into the ring.
The ring also contains a stone from the Garden
of Eden, and so I think it could play a part
in Maze acquiring a soul or something else
that will make her feel complete.
After all, as Amenadiel told her:
"I don't know if a soul is what
you need to feel whole, but...
I do know this.
If anyone is going to find what
they're looking for, it's you, Mazikeen."
Perhaps just like Lucifer and Amenadiel,
we'll learn that Maze has the
ability to self-actualize,
and with the help of her mother's
ring, she will come to believe that
she isn't just a soulless demon after all.
Like Dorothy with her shoes in the Wizard of Oz,
Maze has 'always had the power', she
'just had to learn it for herself'.
A big reveal at the end of Season 5
is that Amenadiel and Linda's baby boy
Charlie appears to be mortal and not half-angel
as everyone had previously assumed in Season 4.
This could somehow be a trick by Michael,
but Charlie does get frozen in time together
with all the other humans in the finale.
And he also got a fever which turned out
to be a cold, something that in theory
shouldn't happen to a part-celestial.
Charlie being an ordinary human does tie in with
a little running gag throughout the fifth season
about the baby's parents being over-optimistic
about the extent of his abilities.
Linda, for example, has arranged everything from
Japanese language classes to art appreciation
events for the 2-month old baby, and
she's convinced he can even identify
elements on the Periodic Table.
And Amenadiel tells Dan he thought
Charlie had some kind of super-strength, but then
discovered he couldn't even hold up his rattle.
This could all tie back to Lucifer's
theory in Season 4 that explained how
Amenadiel had been able to conceive a
child with Linda in the first place:
"When you lost your wings, you
became as mortal as it gets.
Maybe you became more human than you realized."
Perhaps Amenadiel was so human when Charlie was
convinced that the baby never inherited
any of his father's celestial powers.
But there could be something else at play when it
comes to Charlie's human vs celestial nature, and
it relates to an intriguing incident in Season 3.
In the episode "All About Her", Amenadiel visits
the doctor after getting some
cold and flu-like symptoms.
Amenadiel says he's never had a human illness,
but then the doctor tells him he has Chlamydia.
Later on, he discovers, the
diagnosis was a false positive.
The reason for the test results coming
back wrong was never really explained,
but it seems reasonable to think it's something
to with him being an angel and not human.
And I think something very similar happened to
Charlie when he ran a fever which the doctor
diagnosed as a normal human cold.
Something about his half-angel,
half-human nature is likely at the root of
it, and I expect we'll get an explanation
in the second half of Season 5.
Now, there are another eight episodes
still to come in the second part of Season 5 and
there's a sixth and final season after that,
and I'll be going in depth with more
theories for those in an upcoming video.
Season 5 was originally expected to be the end of
the show, which means that the sixteenth episode
would have wrapped up all of the series'
character arcs in a montage of sorts.
What's going to happen instead
now is that the sixth season will
dive deeper into each character's ending.
According to Aimee Garcia, who plays Ella,
we may be getting a full episode for
each character in the final season to
see in detail where each of them ends up.
The ending then will still be the same as
the original ending for Season 5, but it
will just be extended over a full season.
And while we wait for what we hope will be an
awesome final one and a half seasons of Lucifer,
why not check out the epic fantasy
world of Raid Shadow Legends?
If you're like me, you've probably heard
about the game already, but may not have
gotten round to giving it a try yet.
Well, it's one of the most immersive
gaming experiences you can find
for your mobile device and PC,
with a dark fantasy feel and
stunningly rendered 3D characters,
and on top of that it's completely free to play.
There are hundreds of champions to choose from,
and tons of artefacts to hunt for to customise
and make your own unique band of heroes.
The dungeon boss battles in the game are
spectacular and as you try out different
champion and warrior combos, you'll soon
learn their strengths and weaknesses.
The best way I've found to upgrade your
warriors is through farming the campaign
to gain new rewards so you can quickly level up.
And if you're into PvP, the Arena is a great place
where you can test your champions against any of
the million plus players from around the world.
There are also huge weekly rewards for
winning the Arena battles and bonuses
for climbing the tiers.
On top of that, right now,
Raid are hard at work adding loads of new updates
to the game, such as Champion Fragments which lets
you summon awesome Champions like Hordin.
There's also a new Bazaar where you can
acquire high-value items with the
Gold Bars you win in Tag Arena.
And the game just extended the rewards you
get for daily logins to an amazing 270 days.
You'll even be able to get entire new
Champions for free just by logging in.
So don't miss out on a very special
offer we've got for all new players.
Click on the special links in the video
description to get an incredible 200,000
silver and this totally badass champion Grinner
from the Undead Hordes completely free.
After you've installed the game, you'll
find the rewards in your inbox here.
Don't forget you can only get these
bonuses by clicking on the links below!
The offer runs for the next 30 days only, so don't
delay and install Raid Shadow Legends today!
So, what do you think of Season 5 so far?
And do you have any theories on what will
happen now God's arrived or ideas for Season 6?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below.
Tap left to watch my next Lucifer video
with everything you missed in Season 5.
Or tap right for another
video you're sure to like.
And if you enjoyed this, a thumbs-up
and a share are hugely appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!